welcome to this via playing
international master xiran from Turkey
it is Turkish flag to 391 Nessus rating
which means I'm the rating on the dock
after this dip that I that I took rating
wise so try to quickly regain the points
I I really think that 24 and something
to form a little bit 24 22 4 30 this is
about the correct um yeah this is about
the rating that I have here on five
minute on repairing and less some are
considerably lower as is being
underrated ok 94 young does this is
interesting can do various things here I
can take it player 3 and try to prove
that the default porn is slightly
exposed I could also allow him to take
on f3 and then play rook d7 this kind of
idea also on an option or I could be
flexible Rocky III even 92 sm it's not
completely idiotic like we should be
three and then try to take it
night you want even as an idea 91b
should be three it looks it looks
interesting try and Bishop e3 to take
and then night to d3h success is helpful
for white so if i take now and play f3
and 93 maybe 93 first now then he can
play night see no Nazi to have Roxy one
okay then I can start with the smooth
the ideas to take and and then blockade
his pawn so that an end game yeah so
that an end game with minor pieces night
against the bishop would be would be
very much to to White's favor yeah this
is also very favorable
the night is protecting all kinds of
others this is good for might not be
five was much better now i have an
invasion route for the king check ok so
i can go to see to wear yeah that's well
it but it doesn't matter i have time i
can go here play rookie to brooke see to
an end game night against bishop is very
good for me so I don't don't mind that
Roxy one maybe org f1 dunno let's peroxy
1b5 I have Roxy six ok prevented that if
i go to beef go to see form rook c8 king
b5 he exchanges on c1 and play skee yee
five probably ana this is not not too
great ok so let's operate with Luke f7
this is also not bad at all if it goes
back 36 I have this move using the
fifth-ranked so we cannot play b5
gathers very nice he's got all pawns on
dark squares so on a quite substantial
liability how to improve i can i can put
this rook on b5 and then try to maneuver
the night to see phone I was also
threatening night c5 but he prevented
that ok so just here
trying to get this night to see form
I wonder seeker look I've severed its
done to not a big deal it's not a big
deal now I didn't think about that one
and I don't really want to play me five
okay but I don't have any any big choice
here i need to do it otherwise it's lost
so he wants to play with d5
hmm
yeah wow do I need to play before
William before
I don't see em see you something else
hmm what deck
time warning yeah this was bad I lost
control over this position it was it was
really really bad for black check for
cut apart check the some idea that he
can approach with the king what a shame
check check check check
check-check
yeah it's just a good check wait for
phase one time ah what a sick game what
the heck did I do that I mean it's just
ah what a nice end game ah this kind of
game hurts I mean he's really plated I
can oh no way but of course I did the
same I mean he put everything
deliberately on dark squares which
really shows a lack of TG girl play but
if you don't win the end game and so can
you do I think this was this was
perfectly all right and here i need to
do something else yeah I know
technically five seems to win a term it
doesn't seem like the right move to play
check this is this kind of stuff yeah it
just picks up the porn if he goes here
then then before yeah just just dead
lost he killed his own bishop and I will
yeah I tried it the slower but I
underestimated this idea that he had
texted us yeah he 6 is still winning
yeah just a bad game just a bad game
this is still winning but this is not
not so easy to stack when limited time
check the computer finds this in scale
and the white wins but again this is for
human holy already difficult when T is
still is six is good for white but okay
I lost control Chad this is just
getting getting angry sorry jack check
check he didn't even try to win on
position it's not necessary i'm down on
seven seconds but it really hurts to not
have won the same game because what he
did is he played a couple of really
terrible news i mean i need to point it
out I dragged you coming through for
some reason I mean this is already
already tricky for black the computer
doesn't recognize it it gives it as
equal this is nonsense white is better
here and after this white is
substantially better this is just
unspeakable putting something else on
dark squares and check after after this
kind of stuff like a sara lee in dire
straits but okay i didn't didn't realize
the advantage correctly what i just want
to point out is that it was completely
unnecessary to give me to give me the f5
square plus g5 the b5 square you gave
away all those quests just yeah i don't
know for what and my pieces are are
ready to invade i simply didn't finish
it off correctly but this is something
you need to be very cautious about
putting your pieces are you pawns on the
same color complex than your bishop it
tends to weaken them the other color
complex here the light squares alright
thanks for watching